[Music]
mikey fisher thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders this is great
thank you so much michael a huge fan of
yours as well so
thanks so much for inviting me on thank
you so you're talking from campus from
stanford right now right
i am i am pulled up here for a little
bit it's been great kind of working it's
kind of like clustering in while i
finish the last bits of my thesis
right so phd at stanford and you're
focusing on law artificial intelligence
you're writing a book about regulating
and artificial intelligence
and tell me about your path what why are
you what what is this intersection of
law and ai where does this come from
yeah um so it's a little bit so i
originally
started i love computer science
obviously i've been doing it for a
really long time i did undergrad here at
stanford
always been very involved in research
and
um you know learning about the newest
things and then
sort of ai came along and i got involved
with that as that was sort of right as i
was starting my phd
and so i like realized quickly that this
was going to be
sort of a non-incremental thing that was
coming
and so i sort of switched gears a little
bit and started going
into um ai my interest has always been
around sort of democratizing technology
so thinking about like technology is
this great enabler and how do we
um make it more accessible and
also and how do we use technology to
also make it more accessible so
the thing that struck me as being a huge
need is right now
programming languages are extremely
difficult to use you know
people c plus was it was interesting
python
javascript you know it's constantly
getting easier and easier to program
it's still it's still very tricky to
actually understand
to break down a problem to learn the
syntax
to learn how to debug something all
these things require you know a year of
expertise
before you can even build sort of a a
program of
some size and this seemed ridiculous to
me
because um i envisioned a world i mean
my dream is a world in which
you know you can just talk to your
computer and then it could develop the
program for you why do i have to
know how to tell it what to do in a
programming language why can't it come a
little bit closer to me
and i can say you know if bitcoin goes
below
uh uh seven thousand dollars order two
more
and like i could build a program that
can do that but i probably won't do it
because
it's too tricky to do so but it would be
nice if i could just be telling my
computer all the time
um these different programs that i would
like and they could then build them for
me
so i looked into so my research is on
sort of how to you how to what is the
next generation of programming
languages going to look like and my
vision is that it'll encompass a lot
more natural language so you'll describe
to the computer
in in some in not totally bizarre terms
but it's something that you can
understand
and then it can then use a translation
sort of in a very similar way in how
english is translated into spanish by
google how can you translate
english into a programming language like
a very simple javascript or a very
simple python that's sort of
based around these sort of trigger
action commands that people typically
want to do
so so you're literally doing a thesis
you're doing a phd at stanford
about what is the next generation of of
human computer interaction going to look
like but from
a development perspective so not
necessarily the consumer
you know alexa buy me more toilet paper
it's more i want to pro i want to
think of a new alexa and i want to talk
my computer through working it out
exactly or demonstrate another one is
we're working on is a demonstration so
i just want to maybe show my computer
what to do like click this button click
this button
but um only click this next button if
the price of hand sanitizer
is below ten dollars and if it's not
then do this so you're sort of
these these next generation programming
systems that are
allow either natural language or
multimodal interfaces
or um or programming by demonstration
to allow you to build these sorts of
programs that will run on
um if i say alexa it'll pop up and there
it goes
it'll allow these next generation
systems to run um on
these virtual assistant type devices
interesting and so mike you're writing a
book called regulating ai
what is that about yeah so i'm always
been interested in ai and
as i was uh doing more and more of it
the the social implications became
more and more pronounced and you know
especially being in stanford stanford is
all about
the intersection between technology and
um
society for a lot of things uh it's not
i mean
there's other schools that are very
technology focused there's other schools
that are very
human focused but i think stanford is
one of the things that sort of brings
those two
things together sure and so i mean
that's always been
top of mind to me and uh i took a class
a couple years ago
on um regulating ai i did well in it and
then the next time it was taught
um the professor asked me to be the ta
for it
and of course i was extremely excited
because this professor is a
california supreme court justice so he
knows the law backwards and forwards
and he's been thinking about law and ai
and this class got me thinking about it
a lot and then being a ta for it also
got me thinking about you know we
obviously want
ai we need ai out there but we need a
little we need more
um clear understanding for both sides
for for
from society's perspective from the
people who are building it nobody wants
to release a self-driving car if they're
not sure
what how how it's going to be penalized
when something bad happens they want
some clear
it it's helpful for both sides to have
some clear regulatory framework
so that there is the law always the law
always finds a framework
i mean it's just not clear before it's
if you want to make it clear before it
happens as opposed to after it happens i
mean someone will sue someone else and
some judge somewhere
will review the case and come up with a
ruling on it
it's just very um inconsistent or
uh haphazard so it's better to like
maybe think about it a little bit not so
much that you think about it so much
that
makes so many rules around it that you
stifle innovation because that's bad as
well
but just so that there's some framework
around it so um i've been thinking about
these ideas a lot i've been teaming the
class
um uh and so i thought it would be great
to
get these ideas out there more and i
thought the best i mean even when i was
doing the class i tried to disseminate
the knowledge as much as possible by
opening it up to um auditors people who
had
people could just sign up on it we had
an email list where you could stay up to
date with the class announcements and
the wrong materials very trying to like
mooc the course just sort of ad hoc
and so that's good and so then i thought
like it would be great to write a book
and
the law is so interesting so um treyas
and pranab and myself are um writing
this book
and what we're doing is we're thinking
about it in terms of like a primer for
people who want to learn about law and
also a primer
for people who want to learn about ai so
then we're sort of like taking different
concepts
um and then tying them together so we're
looking at like
self-driving cars and then we're tying
that together with
product liability and tort law so we'll
give like a primer in what is a
self-driving car how does computer
vision work
how does patching work and then tying
that together with product liability and
tour line these interesting areas a lot
we're looking at like
generative ai so how does ai produce
like
ideas and trademark trademark things
that can be trademarked or words that
could be copyrighted or things like that
and then tying that together with patent
law and copyrights and property law
like sort of those things and giving a
primer to both and then merging them
together
so michael let me i want to i want to
pick your brain on this so i recently
saw this
this wide study about the trolley
problem where they presented in very in
many countries this question of these
various scenarios of the problem i'm
sure you're aware of the study where
millions of respondents said
whether they would uh have an autonomous
vehicle
uh go one way or the other let's say and
and
a grandmother or a baby right yes and um
and what i what was very surprising was
that for ever
different countries had different
responses to this based on their
cultures
and i always thought to myself how does
what are the implications of this in
terms of the law
and how are different countries going to
regulate sort of ai
in their own sphere and what happens
when one country develops
technology that another country uses do
you have some some idea behind these
things
yeah i mean a lot of countries um i mean
like i think
singapore it also like all these things
are cultural too
so definitely like um singapore is just
a smaller place it has fewer roads
there's not any
rural um roads in which you know there's
everything's well maintained
the the dividers are all well painted
things probably aren't it's all it's all
very um
res it's all very uh urban yeah um
whereas the united states is just we
have super urban areas like new york san
francisco l.a
we have suburban areas where it works
and urban is really really hard just
because there's so much
inner lab of everything and people and
then suburban suburban's fairly easy and
then rural is just like
actually super helpful because if you
could just drive somewhere and so
um it all these things i don't know that
there is one sort of
overarching thing because all this laws
is a lot in time
entwined a lot with cultural norms and
how people like what it's going to be
used for and um
but certainly some places are further
ahead and even some states are further
ahead like
arizona and texas are doing a lot
um and i think nevada california is two
um and if they're they're doing it in
actually a pretty smart way they're
doing staged rollouts
um in certain areas with safety drivers
which is beneficial i mean it doesn't
always
doesn't work with so we saw in the uber
case where there was a safety driver but
they weren't paying attention yeah
and someone ended up dying but um it's
it's still
i mean if i had to say what they should
do is they need to
um have like i think the safety driver
is is a wonderful idea
and then they just need to have set up
some sort of metric around
when um their errors per
uh mile is less than what you'd expect
for a human driver
and one sort of like right now the
discussion is always around like oh the
google ai car made you know x number of
errors but then if you look at it it's
like much much
less than what you know of course would
make and it's just in absolute terms yes
it is bad but
so many people are distracted with
driving and you know
a lot of the mistakes most of the
mistakes that car accidents happen are
a result of user error and um
we're still coming to terms with like um
is it okay like
is it okay when a human hurts somebody
there's we have a way of dealing with it
but when a computer
does people are still very on edge about
that and and rightfully so because
people are worried about sort of a
dystopic future but they're still yeah
definitely so mike you were also pretty
pretty a pretty big advocate for
for andrew yang and you got to both meet
him and and advocate for him on campus
tell me a little bit about how this
comes into play with your
love for for technology and innovation
moving forward
yeah well the thing that excited me
about andrew yang
was his he was the first politician
that was really pushing the idea of
technology
um being an enabler in government right
now i don't think the us is doing
nearly enough we're so behind in so many
areas
um we should be doing things with
electronic voting with cryptocurrencies
with you know digital assets um laws
that are all digital
and we're not doing any of this and it's
a disaster because other countries are
doing it we're being left behind
and so andrew yang was the first one
that said look i'm a politician
and i'm in technology and to me that was
that was enough that said okay
this guy is really interesting and i
want to learn more about him
um i had dinner with him in san
francisco many months ago
and after that i was like oh i need to
be doing more to help at least even if
he's not going to get elected
i need to do more to just start getting
these ideas out there
and one of the and so his his main thing
was this idea of universal basic income
which i think is a great idea
i mean it basically is gives everyone a
x number of dollars a month
um i think there could be some issues he
was giving it to everybody but
when i talked when i was talking with
voters and everything um
people that were written the idea that
someone who is already making a million
dollars a year
would be getting ubi a thousand dollars
a month really upset a lot of people
so i think there's some areas where it
needs to adapt that to maybe make it
slightly more
so that people are only making some
certain thresholds something maybe
more similar to what we're seeing with
the payment protection program where
it's tiered based on how much money
you're making
but the idea that automation um is
taking away jobs and we need some sort
of
the safety net to keep people from
becoming impoverished is a wonderful
idea which i really stand which i really
support
and so he was pushing that and um i
started the stanford gang gang on campus
so we
flyer we do talking on campus um
we had talks about universal basic
income
we got up i was the representative for
the remote iowa caucus here so we tried
to
get people to caucus for andre yang in
stanford
so it's been a great experience and it's
also been a wonderful experience to
get people a little bit more um
political i think a lot of people here
for the most part apathetic
um and uh so getting some especially
that we had a lot of people who are
computer science people and also broad
spectrum but
we don't typically expect to see people
who are in computer science doing it
definitely so you know right before we
started this show we we had a very
interesting conversation about
about education and technology in
general and
and i think that we we shared some of
our some of some of the different
confusion about where is this going and
what would happen you know if future
generations
would uh use methods like we have
in these weeks with corona times yeah
and and
tell me a little bit about how do you
see this education through technology
what are its shortfalls what are its
what are the good upsides to it
yeah well i mean anytime you go to class
classrooms hasn't changed for 2000
forever
like it i don't think anyone would argue
that having a professor
give a powerpoint presentation at the
front of the room is the optimal way
for kids students to learn like most
people you need more
interactivity you need the stuff the
content needs to be way more engaging
powerpoints it's like it's like going to
see a a high school play versus
a um a hollywood theater a hollywood
production it's just like
when you add production value to things
it makes it more interesting and like
you look at things online like three
blue one brown and the
the content quality is just so much
higher than what you'd normally see in a
classroom
like um master class if you know that
yeah exactly
exactly like the co the quality of the
content is
and it's engaging like they've thought
about it there's a storyline around it
it's interesting
yeah and so a stanford i think like on
there's something there for the online
there's gonna be two camps there's gonna
be people that keep going
the way it's normally going but then
there's gonna be the other camp that
embraces this change and says okay now
how do we really think
about what's going to change like how do
we make the content even more engaging
and more interesting and
and make people want to learn as opposed
to but i think there's also as we were
talking about earlier like there's
something
missing with like no one is no one is
feeling it no one is feeling
excited about zoom well mikey i think
what he mentioned before which really
touched me was
you know classrooms are meant for us to
go and meet people and interact with our
friends interact with the professor
if they're not meant to sit down in the
wooden chair and just stare at the
screen not doing
and my computer science classes right
now i feel like i'm learning just as
much as i was in the classroom because
it's a lecture based
but then there are the classes which are
about the interaction and about going to
the professor after class
and getting their input and getting her
to to
and and pinging questions back and forth
with her which i
which is not really yeah and zoom right
yeah i mean more interact yeah so more
interactive more group projects more
like
experiential learning definitions too
just
um taking notes online um
right and just more interactive yeah i'm
looking at you know augmented reality
into this and uh
obviously i i really and i told you i
really hope that future generations
don't
i that they're not going to experience
exactly what we're experiencing now
because it's just not enough
as far as this and it doesn't make sense
to me that we have so much amazing
technology
that we could be leveraging for
augmented interaction virtually
that we're putting to other uses um
that that i'm a little bit surprised
that this is the best we can come up
with
uh although granted nobody really
expected the whole world
will transition to online education
within a matter of a week
yeah i mean i'm so optimistic for the
future um there's gonna be such
incredible things built out of this time
there's like this is just the start of a
huge
opportunity in which there's going to be
like incredible classes online and
incredible
change changes in health care incredible
change like sometimes you need that
that deadline to really it's like it's
like a deadline for a paper like
that but until like it's due on april
1st it does it
does things actually come to fruition
like you know digital healthcare
all of a sudden almost everybody has to
be able to get their prescription
medicine online
yeah exactly that's not going to go back
to normal afterwards
yeah incredible i'm super curious about
what are the lasting changes that are
going to come out of this and what parts
are going to go back tomorrow give me
one
guess for one lasting change that will
stay afterwards
um i would say zoom call like work from
home could be much more the norm
than it normally would have been before
i think it was gonna be unless
unless someone has a strong need to uh
like unless you need a haircut
or something similar like it's going to
most people are going to do work from
home and
and to build on that there's going to be
a lot more tools developed to make this
sort of
more interactive around it definitely no
you know i think right now
when you apply for jobs a lot of the
times you look at the locations and you
think do i want to work in san francisco
or austin or denver
and it might not really matter soon
because you're gonna you're gonna have
so many more opportunities especially in
the tech world
to work at any company you want because
they will have they will
at least enable you to work from home
yeah because of this experience
yeah mikey before we finish
i want to put you on the spot one last
time and i want you to tell me three
words
that you think would best describe you
hmm
good question i think
i would say
uh fearless because i don't think once
you once you
once if you are afraid of something you
don't think you don't
you don't go for it like you you would
otherwise sure
um judicious so thinking
brings all the way through um
and you know looking at weighing the
different sides of
an argument and
[Music]
exactly like a phd candidate at stanford
and i would say uh another one would
be now so there's this quote i like it's
like
um and along with now would be pithy
these are sort of similar things
pithier now um now there's this quota
like it's like if not
now when and i feel like that's an
important thing it's like
if we're going to do it like there's so
many things that can always take your
time
but like what are the most important
things so like now
would be of course there's times to wait
for certain things with exceptions but
was now now is like an important thing
so if they're not going to do it now
when i love it mikey thank you so much
namaste
thank you mike namaste